oh bro I got a toy room yeah I got a
room for just my toys
I got Michael Keaton Batman the piggy
bank I got all my Terminator gum
[Music]
what's up guys dopa Zola here Thomas
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neal guys
let's get straight into it all right
here we lit up I'm ready to light up
there's no no nice guy clock today this
is the little Duval episode thank you
for being here man what's up what's up
so what's up man you pound me up you
already smoke so I'm gonna are we good
oh yeah if he's already started with
mine you know what I'm saying but I want
some of y'all's to that yeah yeah you
roll them yeah okay yeah
that one is a new cross Fool's talked a
lot and said it was real fire it was
from the Dominican I just met him let's
trade you get one I get one let's do it
yeah
that one right there and these are yours
real quick let's talk about this yeah
these are my new infused you know people
be asking me asking me to start my own
weed and I I just smoke cause I like to
get high you know what I'm saying I'm
not I don't like to sell drugs you know
I don't sell no drugs FYI but I I always
wanted everybody always ask me man when
you gonna put out your own they've been
asking me this for years so I finally
did it and here we are you know 0.25 of
live hash come on like hash rising in
there because I get high yeah it's
infused for real it's infused for real
do you dab it off yeah I did oh no but I
usually I use my um padding rig not a
buffer I mean my puff coat oh yeah yeah
the e-rex yeah I use those
clean pool yeah there's another brand
called the car dice one I use you got
one it worked and I can get you one I
mean let's smoke up we uh I didn't know
I didn't know and you take a dance clay
I don't think you know where you're at
yeah all right I think I might smoke
under this table right here I promise
you I hope you do it
don't trick don't don't threat me to a
good time oh I got you we got ball oh
that's the other stuff at our other
student we just moved this is our you're
our second guest in the studio we moved
from our warehouse I like the vibe it's
cool right it's true I wish you could
have let me put my name something on
there y'all
forgot one thing on there and I'm like
[__] if one of my Brands I'm like yo
what am I doing I've ever got like my
biggest friend
what all you got on here oh it's just
push trees just random stuff
yeah dude my dad was on was on drugs
when I was a kid everybody would tag up
the walls it tastes good that's a gelato
cross with a lemon something I don't
they hyped it up though
all right let's get into this real quick
so who are you doing this with you said
holy smokes holy smokes and this isn't
available yet though ain't available yet
this is cool but you can get it at
certain you get it from me my people's
like oh you can get it from western
stores clay excuse me
most of the West Coast for the most part
you know I know you smoke a lot you got
a resin ring already gone it's not
burning Peppers it's burning white this
is good yo I'm impressed already ahead I
gotta be honest with your hands real
with me really hope this I'm talking
about would you would you have been real
real with me if it didn't smoke you know
what it didn't smoke I'd be like oh it's
cool okay and I would have just kept
smoker I want to hurt people's feelings
man I'm gonna stop nah I'm a snot I'm
booze you with my weave heavily I have
no problem with telling somebody they
got damaged me because I take it
personally
I take it pretty when somebody give me
bad weed cause I'm not gonna give you no
bad week you know what I'm saying so if
you give me bad wheel I'm gonna take
almost like especially if you're in
Black Water now if you say hey man it
ain't the best I can respect that but if
you say boy it's gonna put you on your
ass it makes you feel like if that's
what you think is fire yeah oh man I
don't know if I would chill with you
that much in here yeah no I feel you
that one's I haven't tried that one so
you let me know how that one's burning
it's burning good it's smoking good all
right cool cool
[Music]
foreign
what's up guys taking a moment to talk
about one of our sponsors and this is
manscaped breaking news guys manscape is
now selling beard products yes they have
gone from the waist to the face and
they've eliminated that bulky razor so
new for manscape is the beard hedger Pro
kit so manscapes created some of the
best tools to keep your beard perfectly
groomed not look gross we already talked
about like keep yourself groomed keep
your face groomed that's the first thing
people see so keep yourself groomed
right now guys and go to manscape.com
forward slash YOLO that's our discount
code use code Yola at checkout and
that's going to get you 20 off of
everything and anything you buy plus
free shipping this is beard Hatcher Pro
Kit's about to change your life remember
it's waterproof cordless and has 20
different settings with one guard no
more having a drawer full of Clips just
to get your beard trimmed guys
manscape's coming with the titanium
coated t-blade it's tough on hair and
smooth on your face the pro kit also
comes with four dermatologist tested
formulations guys all your hair is
different your beard hair your ball hair
it's all needed to be treated
differently with different products
coming from manscape we're coming with
the beard shampoo and conditioner your
beard hair is much more coarse you're
prone to be getting liable to be getting
ingrown hairs you need manscapes special
formulated beard and shampoo conditioner
treat that beard proper also in the
beard Pro kit for manscaped is the beard
oil that stops the dryness and gives
your skin just a glow a shimmer guys
take care of your face all right if you
take care of your balls take care of
your face if it couldn't get any better
manscapes capping it off with the beard
bomb the beard bomb shapes Styles and
moisturizes beard bomb contains fresh
eucalyptus Rosemary and lavender
essential oils Marty you're not gonna
believe it but it does get better on top
of everything else guys the beard Pro
kit also comes with three free gifts it
comes with a beard brush comb and
scissors to make sure your beard looks
good all the time so go to manscape.com
Yola got 20 off and free shipping
remember that's 20 off by going to
manscape.com forward slash Yola or using
Code Yola at checkout and remember to
check out the beard hedger Pro kit the
premier solution to face grooming
[Music]
let's hop straight into this man let's
do it get off on a little smoking
tangent right here before I forget we go
into it there's a show you started
working on 2019 to 2020. what I don't
know the name of the show there's
something you started working on because
look at this what happened I used to
have a producer right we were smoking
making our videos he goes hey I got a
deal with this network he says TV shows
because I need someone that's funny but
probably easy to work with and I go a
little Duvall the next morning hit me up
because hey we talked to his management
they said they're down to being open
with it and then like two weeks later we
stopped working together so I have no
idea what happened 2020 has right before
2020. that's what we're having problems
oh then it shut down yeah everything's
shut down okay never mind man that was
looking all different shows
pandemic the pandemic shut down yeah it
was my old up real quick that might burn
you
[Laughter]
all right so you're on a tour right now
though back my feet back on my feet to
it all right all right so how many
cities have you done um we only done
three so far but it's about 30 cities I
just I'm just getting back on the road I
ain't been on the road in like six
months because I hurt myself but I'm
back out here now getting back into it
you just got back from Houston no it
just yeah I just got back from Houston
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was it was a
theater it was a theater we did um
I forgot the name of the theater but
Houston always showed me look they've
been showing me love for over a decade
so it's that's like second home he just
did a meet and greets in Dallas and
Houston right there oh thousands of
people showed up that's dope I was
shocked they did not the cops were
trying to shut us down every 10 minutes
they did wow yeah it was a smoking
session no they said that it was a
disturbing of the peace for that many
people to be out there
that's what it's about nowadays just
bringing Vibes you know what I'm saying
just like y'all y'all we just meeting up
for the first time we just vibing just
easy that's what we can do you know what
I'm saying we get to it it's the garage
conversations man I know how many how
many times you've been in the garage
smoke bite it's been three hours I gotta
go the kid was crazy I just started
smoking smoking weed yeah I never I
started years ago I'll say it's been
I've since I've seen you online you've
been smoking yeah no I've been online
for about 20 years I'm old I've been
online since my space but
um I started smoking like five years ago
like when I must have just started
seeing your [__] then because I remember
you smoking plus and dances you probably
saw me in movies with with pool uh grow
house and stuff that was acting you know
I was acting there that's why people be
tripping like that whole movie I was I
wasn't smoking in me or d Ray d-ray
smoke too I didn't smoke at all we was
faking like in that movie but it was
almost like it was it was like telling
me my future foreshadowing yeah
look at me now I had a meeting with DJ
Pooh like uh
six months I went just went to dinner
with us and we were talking he's like
all right there's a movie coming out I'm
filming on this uh Magic Black Magic
Camera I swear to God I can film a
feature and it was a grow house in the
next movie so yeah it's a small world
man yeah four in a minute 60 degrees of
separation it's cool man so how real
quick you didn't smoke at all you're
faking smoking so you're an act you're
acting yeah that's what's happening
yeah so um how was that was that your
first I think I've seen you in other
roles but I feel like
that was more of like you
like main character you know what I'm
saying it wasn't so much like the first
side main character I'm trying to think
and I did Hillbilly Highway before that
Hillbilly Highway yeah that's a weed
movie that was another week I'm telling
you it was almost like it was dead where
people just think you're high yeah
people saw I was even back then they
swore I was high I don't drink I don't
think I do is this and shrooms
messed up
and [__] but I'm not doing it like
recreationally but I want to do it like
now that I like you know once you start
doing you like all right it's a mission
like all right I'm gonna do it this time
on the plane all right this time I'm
gonna do it at the club this time like
so if I would have known I should have
thought about that before I was like
this would have been a dope I could have
prepared myself and we could have got
shroomed up in this hoe yo damn I love
that ABS takes mushrooms
oh yeah see that's a lot of other things
that's why I don't bring a rig on a
break because most people got [__] to do
but yeah I'm truly will ruin your day
the the the damn ain't gonna ruin my day
I'm just gonna keep me happy because
it's rooms don't it's like that [__]
don't stop about six hours it's diving a
part of your regular routine with it
oh oh not really I just dab like when
I'm sitting at the house chilling and
like it's fun to carry around that [__]
you [__] bongs yeah but since I've
been because it's the same damn thing to
me it's like it hit you with when I put
the dab or whatever in that [__] I put
the um the wax yeah the wax in there
give me the same [__] to me it's just
that that ball I can choose
what I do on the other side is I do we I
do like weed tutorials that's what I do
on YouTube that's my [__] yourself
stories I will show you how to [__]
that's why I know
so what what you gonna show you about
the ball I'll show you there's a there's
a technique to not you know when some
people hit the ball and they go oh and
they cover it like and they clear it
that's a Nat that's that's like drinking
warm liquor that's what they feel like
and it hurts your chest yeah then you
have a taste in your teeth you're like
the [__] people do this just give me a
joint I'll show you to hit the bones
you're like yo I'm gonna carry this
[__] with me in the bathroom you got it
now [__] I wanna you wanna hit that
right now yes oh my God [__] yeah all
right here we go pick a color any color
perfect I like that um let me get that
purple one right
hold on
they think they [__] with a rookie
hey man I don't know most people do not
hit bongs damn YouTube's about to be
okay how this one work now I got you so
now this is our collab with prism glass
this is a modular bong it comes in
different sizes and colors you screw it
off and wash it easiest bond to clean of
all time
all right here we go let me get that
water in it
let me get that Marty
all right while we're doing this Marty
you can start we spoke it with flour you
ain't putting the um I thought what's
this now hold on it's a bomb okay yeah
it's not a diabet you're supposed to say
right now okay go away go ahead I do
this with my um what's name too
no I seen backstage a video
you smoking a j backstage with Kevin
Hart he was afraid to hit in shut yeah
so you got no problem before the show
going on in front of a couple thousand
people you're not getting it that would
have come to weed
we just did our first live show we did a
TED Talk and I was thinking about it
before we didn't smoke at all before I
would have been like I'd have been
afraid I'd like Trail off and forget
what the [__] I was saying real quick
yeah I just smoked too much you don't
feel like okay I don't think I can do
the talks without no Ted Talk yeah I
hadn't we had to memorize 18 minute
speech oh yeah oh hell I feel like I was
back in school
no can do yeah I'm gonna rip this and
I'll show you right here so basically
when you rip these bongs man you want to
fill this thing up with the first part
of your lung don't try to clear it all
at once until you're like a [__]
Champ you know what I'm saying so you
like roast it let it build and then
clear watch I don't know if I do it
normally he uses the hempler too that's
a crucial part of it
that way you're not
dying you're not having fun you could
pull it that'd look like a long pool
though I smoke a lot I'll get you right
now you got a shorter I'm talking about
you got a shorter two we do it not here
though like that's a long ass too I
could try it if you don't clear you
don't clear
it ain't no competition
I just want to see if I could do it you
can I got you watch this I respect the
energy you're bringing to the side yeah
most people like oh I don't know man I
don't know
here we go
so just breathe in I'll tell you to go
faster
perfect
now let go and catch your breath
and then now get a new breath and clear
it oh
through the nose you're a champion yeah
[Laughter]
but next to try to clear as fast you can
and it'll taste way better because it
gets stale or the longer you leave it in
there yeah
it was gonna be rough before you do that
yeah it's rough when people just try to
they hit it as hard as it can right off
the bat and they just start choking
they're not having fun and they go I
smoke blunts
and then that's it and then it never
goes back
okay
[__] you want to try to oh all right I
got you go go Marty real quick and I'm
gonna hand it to him
go for it oh [__] yeah all right so
you're on your tour sorry you're on your
tour it's all good we bow we're breaking
and [__] we vibing all right so you're
on your tour right now you're doing
three shows so far
are you ending in your hometown home
state
no I'm still getting back on my feet
trying to trying to get back in the
swinging thing so that's really why I
call it back on my feet tour because
like I said I've been down for a while
with this accident you got a cane with
you yeah yeah man I got hit by a car hit
by a car yeah not in the car accident oh
oh okay yeah so you were you were I read
a little bit but it was ATV in right
yeah no I was on my I was on my yeah on
my ATV and riding on the road and later
behind me hit me hit me from the back
since you're flying residential yeah in
that in the islands oh you weren't even
here oh damn you want vacation chilling
I live in the Bahamas get the [__] outta
do you really
I don't know that you really live in the
Bahamas yeah I'm afraid it's far over
the water man I've never been nowhere
like what he lives on a private island
but that I thought they were like I
thought they were joking you know I
thought they were joking whenever you're
ready the bomb's over here
you gonna hit it come on
yeah let OG try it it's OG clay this one
told me I got you uh I'll tell you where
to start reading go for it
a little hard harder a little bit harder
and then not all as hard as you can
oh got him got him get you over there
go home
you all right
it's packed you're good let's go about
to be high as hell though it's good
though
I'ma hit it again you wanna hit it again
not right now let's talk a little more
because
somewhere safe I might knock that [__]
off all right here we go so some lady
hit you while you were just cruising
chilling
did she stop okay good she thought she
same lady hit me saying lady save me
good [__] yeah now I read you laid there
for two hours what happened stop it it's
the island it ain't like you can go now
it's smaller though right it's because
it's not like your call 9-1-1 it's
turned real naked and afraidish
hey this [__] get real bro and then they
were like yo we can get there but it's
gonna be two hours no it's just like
it's only one mlam on the whole island
you know what I'm saying so I mean you
gotta get it you know so I had to wait
how big is the island
going this way it's from
you could skid from Atlantic to Pacific
I mean Atlantic on one side you can see
both sides of the ocean and wow from
both sides oh at any point
damn why do you choose to live out there
and it's my own Freedom you know I could
walk around I ain't I mean I'm not no
goddamn Michael Jackson or nothing like
that or Drake but I mean I like to have
my own piece where I can Vibe smoke my
[__] you know what I'm saying have my
own people if I wanted to come out and
hang out with me we do it like that it's
just a Chill Spot and it's it's real
country too you know what I'm saying I
like where's country that's what I love
about it ain't like a resort island you
know what I'm saying like countries we
know what they're like jungle
no like like when I say country it's
just like it's just real laid back
everybody chill ain't nothing like
people people barely use credit cards
like that you know what I'm saying it's
just it's like one of them Islands it's
real Island like if like the Wi-Fi might
be out every now and then there's
electricity go out a couple hours of the
day [__] like that but you're getting
used to it it's just living it it takes
you back to the essence of just living
in if [__] if y'all do these rooms y'all
love that type of [__] you know what I'm
saying Hell yeah but it's like the
perfect place how long you've been
living there for
well I my family's from Bahamas but I
but I I moved over there like five years
ago six years ago when you start smoking
weed basically yeah yeah
for real yeah does that make it hard to
do comedy and act and [__] huh
what you mean living over there yeah
like no I mean I still fly back I got a
plane I fly but I'm here now [__] you
know what I'm saying it still works yeah
all right third point no that's true how
long are you gonna be out here then say
you came out here you're gonna I mean I
go back and forth I still got places in
America too I mean I've still got houses
here in other places too I just in my my
daughter live here so I mean I'm gonna
be here till she turned 18 or something
like that but I mean I just go there
when I have like couple days gotcha
[Music]
foreign
us Americans are facing erectile
dysfunction on The Daily fellas you
sometimes need a little help in the
bedroom you get a little bit nervous you
need a little bit of help we're here to
save you the doctors at Rex MD will
evaluate you online and there's no need
to go to a doctor's office and before
the next big day they can ship the
medication directly to your door real
FDA approved medications at the best
price this is what Rex MD is here to
help you with Rex MD makes getting
generic and branded Viagra and Cialis
easy online the prescription included
delivered discreetly and directly to
your door no waiting rooms no
embarrassing trips to the doctor's
office no insurance no co-pays just you
and your ED medication so take advantage
of the best deal ever and it's up to 90
percent off
90. also pay as little as two dollars
per doses with our exclusive link so to
take advantage of this limited time deal
go to rexmd.com forward slash dope Ed
can mess up all kinds of relationships
and things in life we want to avoid that
Rex MD is making it easy and simple with
their online platform with just a few
clicks of a button you're talking to a
medical professional you guys are
putting together a plan they're shipping
your prescriptions to your door
discreetly directly to you within two
days act now to take advantage of this
deal by going to rexmd.com forward slash
dope our exclusive deal will save you up
to 90 which means you could pay as
little as two dollars per dosage on
generic Viagra versus ninety dollars
starter packs of generic Viagra and
Cialis are now available to our
listeners to get started remember that's
rexmd.com forward slash dope and that's
going to save you 90 off plus a free
gift and remember your partner will
thank you
[Music]
foreign
I'm back home what's that fight how long
is that from where Atlanta see I mean I
live in Atlanta y'all see okay okay you
got four and a half hours yeah quicker
yes yeah y'all got a long journey to get
to the Bahamas from from Atlanta to the
Bahamas two hours oh [__] regular flight
yeah on my plane oh you got your own
plan for real yeah no [__] all right
hold on when you got that plane who's
the first person you called like yo I
got a [__] plane this gotta you gotta
have that moment like y'all that's a
good question like a James Bond over
here it might have been ludicrous
he was the only black person that I knew
had a plane for real you know what I'm
saying like most people say they got
they be rent yeah but he was the one was
it him
when did I get my first plane no when I
first got my first plane it wasn't the
plane I got nine my first plane cut off
on me as soon as I landed
it was a Cherokee Piper Piper Cherokee
but it it was cool it was just I had it
wasn't I had to learn about planes
through that plane you're not flying it
are you yeah I'm well I'm still getting
my license this is [__] epic you're
James Bond bro don't I got a C plane too
I got three plays
I'm so afraid of the planes bro I just
tried to [__] pass out when I get on
these damn flights you're over here
flying yourself that's dope it's so
different I just filmed I just was with
uh John Travolta inside a couple days
and he could like a flame plane flew
over called out what it was I could do
that too though oh [__] so that made me
look smart huh
it's kind of like looking at car you
could tell a car from the [__]
headlights yeah well like that's how it
is with planes I can that's uh we both
hate flying with a deep passion it
scares me bro because I don't want to
control how y'all gonna get bigger
though man like yeah we're gonna get
over it again
uh
man y'all gotta get over it man yeah you
know who used to hate used to used to
ride the bus everywhere Khaled yeah yeah
now he's got his own yeah he flying his
own place now he ain't flying but he oh
he got the big Jeff if I could talk to
the pilot and go hey man you like your
life
all right let's do a fight you can fly
my plan honestly that's cool I'm Gonna
Save on my plane then I do the for sure
because you kind of are in control you
know what's up yeah and it's my plan so
I'm keeping it fixed you know what I'm
saying like that I wouldn't trust people
that like renting them planes because I
know what they do in the play they just
get keep them enough to keep them oh
hell I wouldn't trust carnival ride
basically how much of the plane ride is
the computer driving the plan versus the
manual aspect of it like
most of it but it's you gotta know the
computer you got to understand it and
then understand the instruments and
understand when for me the hardest part
is is the wins and understanding the
skies you know what I'm saying that's
the hardest hardest part for me but for
the most part you just reading
everything and and knowing what you're
reading and understanding it you know
what I'm saying do all those buttons yes
100 things I'm mean not now because
everything than modern technology is on
mine I got an older plane so I don't
have most of the modern day technology
but only thing difference is you using a
laptop or it's like using old gauges in
the car or using how the everything iPad
now in the car yeah like Tesla so that's
the difference in are you into jumping
out of planes and [__] like that I mean
I have yet I mean
yeah but that was is this pre-weed yeah
this is pre-week okay
that'll give me anxiety attacks we're
thinking about that [__] you know what I
can't do now since I've been smoking I
can't do no type of ride to go in circle
no more since I started smoking like
motion sickness almost yeah it's like
almost [__] me up now that's the only
side effect I've had from this I can't
do [__] like that spins like yeah that
[__] [__] me it sounds horrible so
you're a rare breed you never had to
smoke trash that's what I tell people
they mad at me because I skipped online
you didn't grow up with some nickel bags
and [__] we've never seeds and I came in
with Snoop you understand like stupid
[__] tickets hey to this day Pooh had
the best weed I've ever had it was
called uh Abracadabra
Abracadabra like from Half Baked and
[__] that's what came out of my uh that
came out of my movie at the girl house
he put it in that [__] was real oh it
was the straight yeah the strain was
really Erica dabs is a dab uh strain out
here oh yeah this damn this he had this
like 10 years ago when we ever shot the
movie but he had the best maybe because
I first started to but to this day Snoop
got some [__] too that's good as hell
but he only he he he got some [__] that
tastes like bubble gum and I had other
bubble gums
from uh I've had that too
spray huh it's sprayed it's sprayed it's
an artificial uh flavoring in the grow
process don't tell me that yeah just so
afterwards they can be like I didn't
spray my [__]
Armageddon tricked my ass ha you know
where you [__] pretend those arm
again you hook up all the TVs like
there's a nuclear bomb this boy had like
eight cameras on my ass I came over
there to look at packs I thought I was
just coming to smoke weed and then I'm
over here calling my girl like [__]
meet me downstairs I'm running he's like
Thomas finish the joint there's like a
whole thing of the news there's a bomb
hitting L.A if you're within this you
have to get out of this air I'm like are
you [__] he's chilling smoking a
joint he's like that he's like texting
as a girl I'm like oh my God this is
real
he has an evil as I'm running down the
hallway all the doors open three camera
people everybody's laughing at me and
[__] the last time we went over to King
Louis the 13th spot bro that's the last
experience with them yeah they did some
punk [__] and coffee dude is it on
camera yeah they feeling the [__] out of
it I never saw it maybe in like five
years they're just gonna bust it out
they're gonna wait to you all the way
below
it was funny though I was panicking like
it's funny now that next level you're on
Joe Rogan level and he's like I do not
want this to come back oh you know what
I'm talking about it now
cause you cool with it it don't matter
[__] it I don't care but that's the
little experience speaking of Snoop
you got a song on your YouTube channel
with them at 54 million views it's just
pop that [__] I remember the suburb that
[__] was dogs how did that come about
I don't know if y'all believe in God but
I believe it came from God through me
because it's just a Vibe of my energy
who I am everything that song is is who
I am it's smile I smile [__] I live in
my best life I ain't going back and
forth with nobody it's exactly who I am
and I just put it in the song most of my
songs are jokes are some who I am and I
just put it in the song so that was just
a reflection of one of my jokes smile
[__] when people used to be down I'm
gonna smile [__] no for real you got a
lot to be smiling for you like Snoop
today so that's really where the song
came from and then he got on it took it
to a whole another level and here we are
I don't know that came out man how I
just moved to LA I had just moved here
when that came out it was like what that
was like five years no six where are you
from originally uh Middle's California
by Fresno well if you travel you know
yes you know where the goat is we might
not grow it but everybody
we shot the meat no we tried to close
somewhere though but it was a weed spot
there too that had some good weed uh by
Sacramento like an hour out of
Sacramento so nothing but weed Farms out
there oh up north by Sac oh I know where
you're at where you're at it's just like
what you talking about though but they
got all the best weed right in the
middle of California was drugs
you the plug man
already
[Laughter]
but yeah you got to skip the line Sorry
back to that real quick you never spoke
no dirt weed in your [__] life so
that's right I hate like if matter of
fact out of the hands like when I'm in
the islands it's the worst week I've
never honestly America got the best weed
in the world of me like Cali Cali by far
to me is no doubt it's the bay and
California I mean like California
Seattle Washington got some good weeds
good hats dude I don't know how to like
I've been all over the world and I've
been smoking a lot of places and I've
never still ain't had nothing better
than cats coming up too Michigan got
some good weed too yeah you're right
you're right you're right they got yeah
they got some good wins man but but man
when I'm over there if I had to smoke
that I wouldn't smoke a weed
you know what else I can't do too much
like um guava like a lot of my friends
they like guava Leaf is it oh probably
Gravely I don't [__] with that [__] hurt
my throat I like tobacco me neither yeah
I [__] with papers and I don't if I do
it backwards because I'm in the club my
whole boys and ain't no they don't
that's all they got left I gotta hit it
but I don't even like that neither but
I'm paper paper type of [__] no for
sure same here that's all I spoke all
right so when that song came out and
dropped you're doing your thing and I
feel like
it kind of sparked an energy that people
needed you know what I mean that's what
it was for yeah I feel I feel like since
we were talking about it on on the live
the other day but I feel like music has
taken a
not so happy turn [__] it's a
reflection of what the world is now what
America is so to speak you know what I'm
saying that's all music that's all
hip-hop is we could say it's messed up
but all the hip I was is just in the
news to tell us a reflection of what the
streets is you know what I'm saying so
that's the same thing
so who'd you grow up like who are your
favorites growing up as far as what as
far as like rap music well I know he's
singing I grew up I grew up [__] I'm
older so I grew up like what everybody
grew up on in the 80s hip-hop you know
what I'm saying Eric B Rakim
um
Jazzy Jeff Fresh Prince
I grew up everybody grew up on the same
thing in the 80s you know it ain't like
now where you you might like this thing
they might like dead things yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying so I grew up on
everything that's what
most of my comedy is is hip-hop infused
you know what I'm saying is because
that's what I was more inspired by
hip-hop than I was comedians comedy you
know what I'm saying I was just comedy
just was in me you know what I'm saying
because I was one of the guys I used to
rank on everybody because I grew around
the at my school there was a bunch of
athletes most of the people they ate
Hall of Fame and football players yeah
because I'm in Florida you know Florida
we was known for football so they used
all I couldn't play no Sports I used to
rank on them all day you know what I'm
saying so that's how I came up I've
noticed like the path of the rapper and
the comedians almost the exact same it's
the same exact muscle it's the same
thing the special is the album that's
why Def Comedy Jam was so big because it
was an infusible yeah that [__] was
hip-hop and Comedy All in One you know
what I'm saying music comedy it's just
like Everything Entertainment is every
if you look at entertainment now
everything is all evolving into one you
know what I'm saying like you got come
like some people see this I think I'm
still working on this oh [__] I'm still
working on this but some people
some people look at y'all what's that
it's a deep inhale you just took it oh
cinematics favorite that [__] can y'all
do this hold up go yeah I feel like this
garage moment
you mean zero the bong hit
can y'all do that hold you then open
your mouth and then do it can y'all do
it
right now I've never I've never tried
man
thank you
all right all right so we're talking
about rap all right you go buy a little
Duvall
there you go okay
I never had that I've never had anybody
do that because I mean it's good though
oh yeah when you get that's a good test
though that's a test for everyone at
home if you can hit that weed and you
can breathe deep and you don't get that
contraction that [__] to clean weed
because if you could breathe deep you
can it's like taking a dab you can't
inhale a horrible Dad no you can't you
can't it just starts hacking it you know
what I mean it's a good little test try
it with mine now try with mine see if
you can do it with mine all right so you
see if you say that's the test let's see
it
favorite little rapper of all time good
question you got you got little rappers
you go by little Duvall little rappers
of all time best Lane bossy vert you got
a little pump I'm gonna go a little bit
I'm gonna go Lil Boosie that's my [__]
bro that's my name is hilarious that's
my dog I want to get about here so bad
big money
man there's hash in it come on huh yeah
come on and there's hash in it what
strain is it
they don't say do you know what's
training I mean I don't know if you want
to say yeah I'm I'm saying this wrist
broke it's my strength oh it's your
strength yeah you see what they say no
that lineage man I was like what is that
taste taste families it's a little
Duvall they got that taste richbroke.com
it's broke you got all kinds of you got
accessories you got merch on there yeah
which broke is kind of like just a way
of life you know what I'm saying it's a
lifestyle that's really what I'm doing
it's just about pretty much saying
living in your means like you can live
your best life in your means like you
don't have to be a billionaire to do
whatever you want to do exactly what I'm
saying so that's what I and you don't
have to try to keep up with the Joneses
to live great you know what I'm saying
that's what people mess up they try to
keep up and then when times get hard
they can't because
forget about taxes fools forget about
tax especially when you're independent
or independent contractor that's well
all the comedians I worked with a lot of
stand-up comics and the pandemic just
like really leveled out the playing
field for everybody background give us
some background you don't know Marty's
back what he's been doing for the past
10 years before this oh yeah I mean
a lot of the big Comics as far as their
graphics and other ads working with the
venues I mean like just behind the
scenes basically for like a long time
before I started doing this so so you've
been around comedians a lot yeah and
there you know yeah this was modest as
hell did all this [__] for rogue and
Theo bonds all the fires in the kids all
Adam Carolla
that's probably where you met him yeah
so that's the background I know they
don't know each other's backgrounds a
lot a lot of communities that don't
matter though like that's what [__] like
this here do but go ahead no a lot of
them really had a hard time getting
through the pandemic like you're off the
road and it really forced them to like
really see who had the strongest fan
base who has the biggest connection with
their fan base and the strongest social
media and [__] right and it's like you
look at your social media we did the
math on it you post like oh hey
thousands some post-hunting oh my God
some thousand like I've been on
Instagram my whole life damn near I post
like 3 000 things on there so like my
point is is like when the pandemic
happened did you did your social media
is that when you started going like
crazy numbers on it with like that
number's always been crazy like I can
show you all my engagements it's been
like this for and I'm not exaggerating
for 10 years like 100 million a a week
because I I understand it people are
social on there and they like where I am
my page is like a hub for a culture yeah
you know what I'm saying it's not just
about you it's not just about me it's
about the culture of it you know what
I'm saying so when they come to my page
they they come for me but at the same
time they come for each other you know
what I'm saying they know it's a safe
place where you can be yourself you can
talk this that whatever and I'm not
gonna you know what I'm saying uh be
offended or disabled you can talk [__]
to me as long as you ain't being
disrespect you know [__] we cool you
know what I'm saying so and over time
I've been like that for social media a
lot you know what I'm saying it ain't
just Instagram it's been like I said
I've been on there for just my space you
know what I'm saying so over time it's
kind of like podcasting you'll see over
time you build a a audience that grow
with you you know what I'm saying so
sure it's just like like safe is the
morning show like what Morning Show you
grew up on oh in the morning I watch
cartoons man well in the morning shows
more than show on the radio people every
day they go to work they listen to that
morning [__] but you don't realize you
listen to them every day for 20 years
really a part of your family oh yeah
same thing with me with social media
I've been in your ear posting every day
for 20 years so I'm really everybody
family he's up saying like that yeah so
it's it's I just use the social media
the same way we use and everything else
so I use that to to build who I am and
to show who I am and like I said I
started when social media was really
sociable and so most the people and I
keep it like that I don't try to
monetize off it like that I just be
myself and it's got me this far so I
keep it like that and that's why people
respect it too because I don't sell
myself like most people be selling a lot
of stuff I got my own website and I sell
my stuff but even my stuff out on sale
but I'm not going to just sell some [__]
just to sell it I sell something if I
that's what took me so long with these
because she didn't even care before we
started talking yeah it's like I'm not
I'm not a sales person but if I like
something I sell it you know what I'm
saying like I'm not gonna put my name on
something just because you're you yeah
you know what I'm saying because I put
left a lot of money on the table just
I'm pretty sure y'all get ads you know
what I'm saying of course you know y'all
this is brought to you by pinochle you
know you know you were completely
independent we passed on oh hell yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying and I
don't knock people that do it because I
understand the business but for me and
I'm genuine people see it and the reason
why they go what I say you know what I'm
saying so if I say something they're
gonna go with it and I feel obligated if
it's just like if I tell you a movie
good it ain't gonna watch about this
Fool's opinion is trash yeah you know
what I'm saying so they they respect my
opinion or they they value my opinion I
try to try to think about that when I do
[__] it held your integrity yeah it's
your credibility same thing with him and
his fans same exact thing we do that
because like I said we do all the
reviews on weed [__] and if it gets on
my channel there's a reason why it's
there like I'm trying I'm you know I
mean these people mainly it's because
the owners or whatever were chill that's
really a lot of the reason I work with
people like I people offer me money like
this guy's a [__] [__] too many
people why
and it's different in my world like
everybody to go for the dollar I'm not
one of them guys that go for it like
it's like I don't care about the money
enough I've had it enough to know like I
had enough to know I don't need
everything to have have peace and
happiness so I and when I got in this
guy I got this game so I don't have I
could do what I want to do exactly you
see what I'm saying so yeah when you get
to that point you really do what you
want to do and most of the [__] I want
to do is not even it's not even sell for
[__] it's really for other people I get
people get more out of music I get out
of myself but that's why I get I get my
fulfillment for seeing them get [__] out
of it you know what I'm saying so relate
to that 100 for sure no I get it I get
it it's just uh I'm trying to buy
[__] in my family houses while
I'm trying to buy a house you know what
I mean like I feel like if I can help
them win help them win it's like a ease
off
it's way funner that way man like that's
why it's fun right it's fun I get more
fun Perfection seeing like I want to
make him a a multi multi-million I
wouldn't make all of them it's dope like
it's
I love it I don't even have to get
nothing I don't even have to talk to
y'all again it's just I love to see that
type of [__] yeah you know what I'm
saying because you just little [__] just
that's right you know what I'm saying
you look and you see this in streaming
too you like that's why it's impossible
to be arrogant in those rooms because it
humbles you you seize it for what it is
you understand how we all connected yeah
even something like this here a spark
something that goes somewhere else you
know what I'm saying so I love all this
[__] 100
yes that's exactly like everything
you're saying he started to get some
real success this past year two years
the first thing he did was let me look
out for everybody first it was amazing
to watch everything you can't look out
for everybody
well you've been on so I mean you'll be
on the internet enough to understand you
could see who's in it just to use you
for the come up you know what I'm saying
that was years ago I I yeah yeah I'm
shocked I got God got that many times
and I know you probably were like I
didn't even see that [__] I
thought he was chill he's a piece of
[__] it's happened before I know it's
happened to you before too in the
industry but I've kind of got that cloak
on now like no I'm a [__] I could see it
on you get away I can see it quick like
I say I've
I've kind of molded people to I
understand what they do like even before
they was tweeting they didn't know how
to tweet I I kind of mold them how to
tweet you know I'm saying like even the
words like basic [__] and [__] like
that this in the terminology now they
come from me tweeting you see what I'm
saying now you got Mac products using
that yeah but that comes from that shows
you the psychologically how you can
finesse and and getting people's minds
and hearts and and use [__] and that's
what I always do but I use it for the
good to to flip it to to make everybody
come together you know what I'm saying
to make now when I said if I say man
these basic ass shits I don't have to
second get it because y'all understand
it so it makes us cooler together you
get what I'm saying true yo
on the mushrooms what's the most biggest
dosage you ever had I'm scared still man
oh yeah yeah what's that mean I'll be
respecting yeah I respect to use that
[__] I'm saying like like I could do in
the hardest part for me is eating the
[__] yeah I just saved your
life you know what I was trying I put in
an oatmeal cookie no hell's dry yeah dry
fruit roll-ups when they go around when
you're biting it it stays together so
when you break it down you don't have to
chew all the mushroom down you don't
never taste it that's the hardest they
got caramel chews they got gummies
I'm in the South so you got to be in
especially with all these drugs going on
you got to be careful who you get that
type of [__] yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying so I don't get it from nowhere I
can't see them I'm saying so if I can't
sue you like I'm gonna get edibles from
everybody yeah because like now they're
fitting all [__] oh you don't know what
they mixing so yeah I don't get [__]
like that unless it's from a rubber bull
like if I'm in Cali and I know this this
store got some good [__] yeah I [__]
with them but we've had a lot of people
talk about like really setting their
intentions and trying to use it to like
further themselves grow themselves all
that type of stuff it's been like
shrooms them blue in the last couple
years too like I mean it's always been
there but like it's been got cooler now
in our culture now you know it's wild
right isn't it weird it's become illegal
it's because people like me and people
like there's other people in hip-hop
that's been doing it they like I ain't
been doing it neither but I just started
too but when I started doing it was like
one like oh my god when it was the first
time you ever took it
well the first place I take it in oh
the first place I took it was at the
house it was me and me and my man five
mics and that was the long that and I'm
a comedian that was the hardest I ever
laughed in my life I laughed so hard
cried laughing like everything was funny
it's like when you shroomed up every
little thing is funny like even that
part that boom boom boom it was just so
funny and and that same thing I started
crying because Jayski went to jail that
day my homeboy he went to jail that day
and I was just boom boom boom and just
in the feelings cause it's it makes you
it made me so emotional like yeah it's
emotional rollercoaster but it's a good
emotional roller coaster so that was the
first time I did it was at the house by
myself well not by myself with friends
was it daytime or nighttime it was
daytime
I stayed in the house and I went in the
bathroom by myself and it was pissed off
[__] and I saw the Matrix I could see
all the grid yes I see the gray before
too this that I wasn't green though uh
it wasn't green I'm not sure I don't
forget but I saw the grid and then two
you know what else you see like once you
on shrooms you realize every everything
that was invented they was on shrooms
bro oh bro the radio come on no the 100
Bill 100 billion dollar bill Clinton I
got cards
let me see it real quick the hundred
dollar bill you know the little hologram
oh that should come up damn
that's one of the scariest things you
can look at and get zoomed into who's
going to find something it ain't really
scary because once you understand the
trip it's like yo it's
like you you gotta it's like a roller
coaster ride you just gotta let it do
what it do you gotta look oh yeah yeah
you gotta ride but the last time we did
them we were on the show with the guest
Josh Wolf and he ate a shitload I ate a
[__] it was these butterscotches we
didn't realize
dude three grams ish but I was oh
that's the most I could do I can't do it
but I was trying to hold a conversation
and I didn't know how much time had gone
by and I went am I not holding the show
down did I just [__] up and you know
what I mean I kept having that anxiety
and [__] look what was it there
the blue strip
no this this [__] this [__] not
the strip the the face right oh the
inside yes that comes up bro
if you do this room this didn't come up
he come up
it looks like the it looks like the uh
the mom from The Goonies I'm telling you
stay woke nah scary lady
oh hell no all right so no mushrooms
yeah we dabble heavy he goes like seven
eight grams locks himself in a dark room
yeah
um I don't I don't suggest unless you're
ready no I'm scared of that too I got
some I got some at the house out of here
for three years yeah I won't do it
because I'm just kidding I'm scared
I saw that Mike Tyson um story where he
said he did and he's like man I thought
I died
that's just scared the [__] out of me oh
it's not gonna be fun either you're
[__] you're puking everywhere you've
done it before no I just heard about oh
my seven grams it was a
no mushrooms it was uh it was eight
grand but I wanted I like to do it in
dark rooms all right next time you take
mushrooms go in a dark room put no music
on and then what is gonna happen it's
pitch black everything you think you see
it's like intense I've done that yeah
that's why I told you I was in the
bathroom oh so oh yeah
yeah that's all the grid bro I saw I saw
a bunch it was wild you saw a smaller
it's too long of a story but I saw
myself what else we do floating you saw
yourself I was floating around my house
looking down at my body and when I can
move I can see my body move yeah but
like my brain was like don't worry don't
worry don't worry that shot off in the
[__] face and [__]
you shallows me I was driving space I
was talking to fools that you're like yo
I know they I like I knew him like like
homies that you have but see you got to
pay attention to that though oh I
remember but you gotta pay because
there's something in there like I told
you there's something that this is how
this happened so you just gotta figure
it out that's why I think about it all
the time still I know the whole story
like I watched a movie I remember what
this fool said I remember where he took
me I was walking over a village watching
people move I was like they don't see us
like don't worry they don't see us I was
walking on nothing in that story you
just got to figure it out looking
forward to making sense that's why it's
gonna make sense yeah no it's gonna make
sense but you want to make sense now so
you can make some money off this
all right let me think well I do have
the legal mushrooms coming out so you
see that's what I'm working on too yeah
I want to put out some shrooms so I just
because I really think they're good for
people you know what I'm saying you just
gotta know how to do it illegal ones
though right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I haven't found the ones that
are strong enough to make me go oh [__]
all right let's take them yeah the other
one's like
I feel I feel them they're cool they're
micro doses it almost two micro dose I
feel I feel like I ain't gonna make a
big ass gummy like a fruit and [__] it's
yeah it's weird it's gonna be like 10
tries to feel it I kept trying to dip my
toes
took like a [__] month this one took
four grams and he was like I'm just
chilling at all waiting that's what
happened that's the worst too though
that's that's what need to be addressed
I hate fake mushrooms it's like that
[__] really be pissing me the [__] off I
ate like you know you eat them because
that's a lot nothing going a lot of
people putting out them fake ones that
it don't be it don't do nothing it's
just you don't get high because you know
you're waiting on that hat yeah but I've
broken them over like you're doing your
hand like this
I hate that [__] but when you find the
right one
it's amazing
what's that one they call Pete that um
goat piss or some [__] like that I
forgot oh you're talking about the
strains of mushrooms no yeah the shrink
oh there's so many [__] weird-ass
names we had somebody on here uh raw OG
he's a YouTuber this dude no this this
dude does the lemon Tech you ever heard
of that you grind your mushrooms down
you squeeze lemon juice into a cup then
you mix them and drink it because the
acid helps you absorb your body faster
but he's like I'm thinking of my
attention he's like going to Whole
meditation [__] thinking about what he
wants to dive into Snoop put me on the
um the the putting it in the weed does
that work it's a different type for me
it was body it just felt like a body
like it was a Vibe have you tried that
uh we did when we were when I was in the
high school I grinded up and put in a
blunt but also like I was [__] drunk
you didn't understand how to take these
rooms no because I eat mushrooms hella
times already I'm like let's try it in
them anybody that do shrooms too I want
to say to have your babysitter which if
this is your first time somebody always
coach you through it you know what I'm
saying because you're gonna need it you
know what I'm saying cause you ain't
sometimes you might not know what's
going on you're gonna need somebody to
guide you because if you don't go you
might go left you know what I'm saying
so if somebody there make sure you have
make sure you have your um you have to
have a baby somebody's sober yeah
but just somebody that know what's going
on somebody that's that's understands
you shrooming oh yeah the first time I
ever ate mushrooms I was 14.
and it was it was fun but being
shit-faced drunk and doing drugs and
then taking shows like as a kid I didn't
get the experience that I get now where
I'm gone last time after we left the
show when I went home oh I was [__]
because you know how to take the ride
talking to me it was you know how to
take the ride now it's like a game like
oh it was like it's like where can I go
yes yeah right that's why I said earlier
like when I like now it's like all right
I want to do shrooms here and then oh
yeah yeah I want to see how it is in a
nightclub now you know what I'm saying
you can always tell when a [__]
on shrooms too they step higher I always
step high like I'm like I'm in mud or
some [__] like I have to be precise with
my steps or I'm gonna fall I don't know
I was like just one time I did it I was
just an amazement I was like I can't
believe my eyes are capable of this it
like made my eyes like Cinema lenses
damn unless you know that a lot of stuff
we just programmed and you because you
see [__] for what it is at that time
because our brain is powerful and they I
guess it Sparks up them [__] this and
you see [__] and you think it's an
illusion but it's really there some
stuff you gotta think like like 20 years
ago
they they dumb to us now but 20 years
ago they thought they had all the sets
you know what I'm saying that's what
shrooms would open them senses up that
the people that invented [__] that we
going on now
that's how they figured it out they
sparked it that's why I was telling you
it's something in that story that you're
saying oh yeah you see what I'm saying
because that could spark something
that's because you really seeing [__]
you just don't know what you like you
said when you're young he's just getting
high [__] up you don't experience the
drug you don't take it for what it is
but now
you can take it you know what I'm saying
but now you're probably looking at video
games like
but now once you get to that level
mentally like all right I can change the
world with this oh see he knows what's
up that's exactly the trip I had on that
yeah
so it's too long but yeah exactly that's
why I'm excited when you said I ain't
telling you stop talking but you got to
be this room to like it yeah it's our
audience it's a perfect audience I'm
surprised we don't have mushrooms on the
[__] set so no we not paid now that
I'm now I feel um real quick we're gonna
do a little segment this is called who
are you in the 90s all right all right
if hey if I'm dragging and let me know
because I'm high as [__] so no you're
good hey man you smoking look at all
this [__] ashtray already I've had a
lot of these two a lot of seasoned
smokers come in here hit it and do this
and for the rest of the episode most
people take it home you know some people
some people want to hold the coherent
conversation I mean one thing about
stuff like this here y'all can show you
better than I can tell you like action
show you know I'm an action guy I gotta
be honest for [__] only smoking for
five years your tolerance is up there I
think it's because my daddy used to do
crack so I got a high tolerance
bro my dad was a cracker yo I was like
that's where my target are we some kids
see see how Strong's bringing us
together he might be severe it's good yo
bro let's listen to My Line like my
parents are doing that's a true story
though but my mama wasn't but my dad he
was
he could take some drugs Thomas was
that's why I won't do strong Drugs
That's why I won't do nothing that'll
kill you because because if I like it
I'm gonna do it like I'm going I had to
stop to a car I did code from like 15 23
years I want to do Coke so bad but I'm
scared I'm gonna like it don't ever do
it I'm not I'm not but but it looked
like y'all have such a good time oh my
God hold on I've never done it most fun
I I love this kid unless you do it yeah
but not anymore because people are
stupid I don't even trust drugs no more
that's why I said earlier it's like
everything just mix you can't trust it I
go with [__] that ain't nobody died yet
here we go here we go this is the
mushrooms all right you might have been
weird at the party off the shrooms I got
in this accident I had to take I had to
take some medicine I didn't mean you
know I don't know how to swallow pills
yo wow you know we know each
I just started taking pills at like 25
years old I don't know how to take I
can't do it bro I can't I feel like I'm
gonna choke to death and I finally got
over I'm still this old and still don't
know you know what it is what you have
to put the pill in your mouth with water
already and then just chug this much
water instantly you don't think I tried
that that's the only way I can do it now
you should put it macaroni as a kid no I
just can't I gotta I got a pill crusher
I got a pill crusher and do it with a
Sprite uh
that's what I do how much pain how like
where are you at with your recovery are
you still in a lot of pain because you
broke your hip wow I'm a femur my wrist
I got a my shoulder how fast she hit you
[__] fast evidently I did all this but
um I've been recovering I actually was
good until I went to Minneapolis and I
hurt myself again on stage being so
excited you fell or something no I
pulled them I well I thought I cracked
my goddamn um FEMA again I thought I
fractured it again because it hurts so
bad but like on stage I felt it but I
played it off on stage and turned that
performance yeah it was a middle of me
performing but but once I got off stage
and I realized what happened were you
like doing something I don't even know
bro it's just I don't know I was on
stage bopping doing my living my best
life doing that [__] and then I guess I
pulled [__]
but
but what whether it came back when I
went into the doctor the next day I
found that it was just a pulled muscle
so I was thankful but it hurt like a
[__] still sorry going back to
the Bahamas you're laying there you got
multiple broke bones yeah it's taken oh
yeah now that we've updated you were
there for broken this
hour ago it's called red City over here
so how did you how did you deal with
that broken bones for like I don't know
if you saw that well for one like I said
I believe in God it was God for one for
two was my mind like you you have to
have a strong mind to go through
something like this I mean I make it
seem like I didn't go through a lot but
I was damn near dying
you know what I'm saying but I'm here so
I got a ton of this a lot of that stuff
is mine you know what I'm saying like
your body gonna do what it's gonna do as
long as you take care of it it's gonna
heal this they made it it's made perfect
damn there you know what I'm saying but
you just got to play the work and
believe and trust you know what I'm
saying and that's what I did a lot of
the um a lot of my athlete friends they
told me hey man you got to really get in
there and physical therapy and put it in
that's what I did and and I got the
results like they told me it's gonna
take me like a year it took me I got
back on stage in two months and I
started like walking
but I couldn't because my arms was
[__] up so I had to be in a wheelchair
for about three months how long ago I
would have thought you were gonna say
like six months yeah I thought you would
say eight or nine honestly two months
you were back up yeah two months I was
back out though did it change you did
you learn about yourself having to talk
to yourself in such a way to get through
all that no it kind of reassured me in
my belief in my faith like because you
know you know people like y'all you talk
that living your best life [__] let me
see if you really about it you know what
I'm saying so this is pretty much if I
didn't have that mindset I probably
couldn't have got through it you know
what I'm saying so it was kind of more
of an assurance of of really who I am
you know what I'm saying I'm really
that's the ultimate test yeah it's like
the test like all right we're gonna see
if you can get through this you know
what I'm saying it's really all
psychologically yeah a game in your mind
it's scary like everybody's walking
around could be faced in that situation
and even in the midst of like it's been
like six months man it missed the six
months people that was praying for me or
was was hitting me in the DMS a lot of
them got accidents in the midst of that
time no [__] yeah it's just it's life
you know what I'm saying you don't
realize till it happened to you you know
what I'm saying so you know I'm almost
died a bunch of times but this was the
worst this was like when it hurt
you almost died a bunch of times in what
way
[__] Planet I got hit by a car before
this ain't my this is my second time
were you walking across the street that
was my fault that time no it wasn't my
fault but it was like where were you at
in Atlanta on uh Old National highway on
a highway
yeah yeah so you crossed the highway
what the hell yeah
and it was before I was even smoking I
wasn't even getting high I can't even
blame it on that well where were you
headed to
there's got to be something like down
I was crossing the street I think I was
I don't know you gotta think this was a
long time ago
and like it was like to this day like
people think I got this from just
getting old like I'm losing my this
that's where this came from listen to
this listen to this guy someone tried to
shoot me in the hair somebody dead in my
head I'm telling you man this one this
is the universe that's rare it's the
universe for real bro you guys got
matches cars and shed oh I got a big ass
dip in my [__] I can pull like for your
birthday September 6th oh okay I'm June
all right June 12th that's wild that's
crazy that dip yeah people are like yo
your mom's punch you in the [__] head
as a baby like nah they think I'm just
losing my hair but it's just when I got
hit by a car you just couldn't tell when
I was young because I had dreads were
you like a kid that was the I was a
grown man oh [__] I was like 20. is that
from the car from hitting it on the
concrete honestly that's from they say
it from the impact you hit me so hard my
head but
oh he really almost died yeah almost
died this time this is way worse though
this one was way worse yeah this one was
like oh yeah but the broken bones but
the head injury days the guy almost even
then like I had um I had to have blood a
blood um
damn you're not [__] [__] that's
really almost time bro but it's a
testament of like how I am now you know
what I'm saying that's why I I move how
I move and live How I Live because it's
people have been way worse than me and
they still out here chilling living
chilling you wouldn't know I don't look
like what I'm going through you know
what I'm saying I'm just chilling
because yeah it ain't nothing I'm gonna
get through it I'm doing exactly so I
don't be tripping no [__] it's just a
chapter of Life at that point come on
but damn they're strong that's that's
bigger I love that Discovery Channel
[__] yeah and then he laid for two I
survived I don't know why that's right
real [__] right there damn
well I'm sorry oh didn't feel like two
hours until I looked you know how I
found out it was two hours when I looked
at my time stamps
like when you look at like when I got
hit I was on my phone and then when I
got to the hospital I looked at it it
was dark I was sitting there so long
were you calling people and stuff why
are you just laying there yeah I
couldn't do nothing what I was gonna do
like that that's why on Instagram it was
like hey you just had to get on the
ground like it wasn't nothing else to do
it was I was sitting there too
huh you went live yeah no stop it yeah
you went live on the ground
oh [__] I went live in the hospital I
went live while they was while they were
doing surgery on my knee crap you're
awake yeah they drilled they just
drilling my knee while I was on online
bro how'd you wait aren't you supposed
to be asleep I'm sorry wait what
happened I was on morphine that's the
that's when I realized why people do
drugs all right you got morphine drill
your knee bro so you're just tripping
and they're drilling into your knee and
you're straight am I like it's online
okay on YouTube but I go on my Instagram
it's on there somewhere if you go all
the way down to July 27th I'm such a
scrub yeah but I'll Google oh YouTube
It's one one of them bro that's the
toughest [__] I ever heard in my life
your soul just yeah you know I want love
yo that's the hardest you might be the
king of social media for that [__]
that's what I'm trying to say like
that's that's social media but that's
why I'm who I am because that's what
I've been on social media for so long
that's they grow with me they live with
me you know what I'm saying it's
literally yeah it's like they follow me
it's like a TV show you know what I'm
saying it's really my live streaming
show but you just let everybody in yeah
it's really my life it's not nothing
fake in it and it's genuine and they
watched it over time
it's just another episode of My Life
I just want to say one other thing about
social media you were hurt on the ground
and people say why are you on the ground
yeah they're still saying why are you on
the way
they thought nothing was like you know
anything for attention you're doing it
for this it's like no honestly if it
wasn't for that I wouldn't it saved me
because everybody thought I was joking
you know so even my friends they thought
they didn't know how bad it was even
like now like now y'all starting when
I'm explaining it most don't know how
bad it was because how my energy is and
my skin of course it came off like yeah
you know what I'm saying so they don't
see it but I really was [__] up [__]
up
that's [__] up everybody thinks you're
joking you're panicking you're like no
that's real kind of thing you're so
funny and nice and smiling that people
think you're joking when you're like yo
please help me I'm [__] hurt but the
lady stayed there and helped you and
made sure yeah she went and got my old
lady and then Molly we sat there man
they called my housekeeper he came and
waited and we just two are we close to
your house I was right in front of my
house I'm telling you even while I was
laying on the ground I was sitting there
like damn I'm gonna die right in front
of mine no I was it was almost like like
it sounds sad but it was almost like
like I've never even in all the times I
almost died before it was all like damn
this time ago so it was almost like
what's up I was like damn for real this
is the end of my story right here in
front of my house at that I died in the
Bahamas it's almost like a perfect
ending but I I don't want them but I
guess this is what it is right you're
okay like yeah I mean it's life bro like
we I'ma see one of y'all and y'all gonna
see me this is life you know that's how
I take it I don't trip off of it it is
what it is
let's go I feel you but hold on we're
all high as hell we started a segment
about 40 minutes ago yeah we never even
started sorry all right this segment's
called who are you in the 90s you said
that [__] a long time ago are you ready
are you ready so it's two things we're
going to give you two options and based
on who you were though in the night not
now no knowledge of 2023 you got to be
in that mindset yeah I was popping in
the nine but go ahead
what was I thinking as a kid okay go
ahead VH1 or MTV
bet
oh no one's ever done that one before
all right you win all right we'll add
that then Adam Sandler or Jim Carrey Jim
Carrey
I even Jim Carrey like
like to me he's the
not just as a comic he's a legend is a
comic like he's really a goat but as a
human being
he get it he understands all he gets it
the he he the truth Jim's his favorite
person of all time well Adam Sandler
yeah Adam Sandler I forget Alexander I
was on FaceTime with him during the
pandemic oh my God yeah that's my uh
that's my uh my [__] guy you're good
dude a guy ever since I was a little kid
man but anyway
Jim carries your [__] real quick
Dumb and Dumber hates matura that's hard
that's what it should be I gotta go with
Dumb and Dumber yeah
comedies you wanna know what I'ma go
with I'm gonna go Anchorman hey part one
of course okay good because I have to
take a man and Step Brothers
[Music]
I'm a Will Ferrell fan yeah yeah I'm a
wheel fair so Ultra Superstar huh
remember that movie Superstar with Molly
Shannon and Will Ferrell oh yeah yeah
old school old school's funny I just
watched it recently Yeah man they really
go hard on that [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah
ties that [__] to his dick
I watched that theater with my family
yeah I'm thinking about like they only
tying [__] to dicks like a bubbles here
hey man all right good good Shake we
watched the same movies then all right
here we go real quick it's not on there
favorite movie of all time
I got two I think one of them is Devil's
Advocate damn we just talked about that
the other day it's because I it's just
really like what life is just with how
the game and it's really what we ended
this business we're in you know what I'm
saying this I gotta go back and watch
that it's like dealing with the world
and dealing with
Being Human you know what I'm saying and
sacrificing it so that's what I liked
about that
what was my other one I don't have to
come back The Devil's Advocate always
what a good choice bro as a kid I never
got when he's in a seller and a seller I
never I've seen that one time you don't
understand you guys you gotta right I
guess you got to be
wait I'm not sure if I've seen this one
it's about space though yeah it's with
uh Matthew McConaughey it's about just
that I've never seen that one oh yeah I
saw the one with Matt Damon he's like
living on his base for like oh that's
more years that's Mars yeah watch that
sorry like the dimensions and understand
how
we all gonna shape into one and oh you
do mushrooms yeah yeah you realize we we
gonna come out of our body soon
you'd like to Avatar imagine right
Avatar one I saw every time I'm still
trying to watch too hard
I didn't even give it a chance I'm
trying to watch too you need to watch it
in the 90s Tupac or biggie Tupac I'm a
Tupac okay
Tupac was damned in my my preacher Bible
like he was my you know Michael we had
the original Machiavelli artwork in this
space not that long ago for real yeah
he's got the painting of up on the cross
yeah [__] crazy legendary actually hell
yeah I wish I had something like that
all right
Pulp Fiction or Forrest Gump
I like this consideration
I'm gonna have a little poke fish oh
yeah that's tough because I mean it
wasn't it was a different level and I
understand it though yeah but Pulp
Fiction like somebody can watch all the
time before it's gonna be able to sit
there like on the I'm just watch it you
gotta get more each time you watch it
yeah all right Pennywise or Chucky
remember it what was the first one
Pennywise you know the movie it with uh
Tim Curry remember it when we were kids
I wasn't a kid when he was ah damn it
yeah it's all right that's right I grew
up on Freddy Krueger Freddy Krueger I
never got scared I was scared of Chucky
on the street when Chucky came I was
probably all right yeah you're not even
worried about the [__] dog bro that
was my position I love Gremlins
we got a gremlin about this big the one
that flashed mascot oh
yeah I got the Transformers
you see the new one that moves yeah I
got all that I got every robot and I got
the Iron Mask Iron Man mask oh bro I got
a toy room yeah I got a room for just my
toys
I got [__] Michael Keaton Batman the
[__] the uh piggy bank I got all my
Terminator gun from apartment I collect
those um those um pops too oh do you
yeah Pops I haven't got into uh you ever
been to there's a place out here called
Frank and Sons it's a toy store just
open one up out here I think him and uh
big boy really a Funko oh no this one's
a it's like a size of a Walmart and it's
like going to a Cannabis Cup there's a
bunch of vendors but they're all toys
one's 80s toys one's 90 toys one's
movies one music when Sports one's cars
ones looking for a garbage pet I mean a
garbage pail kid collection all that
shit's there they got everything I
bought the I bought the [__] Grill
and the Flasher there I get all the
[__] uh my action for you to see
those realistic ass toys that come with
like guns and [__] I got all that the
mask Jim Carrick all that places the
[__] so yeah yeah he's got a
sledgehammer I got Milo with the mask on
mask stands up by itself yeah the mass
stands up it's got the money the clock
everything's super it's adult toys bro
yeah dildos
adult toys not dildos there you go go
ahead all right we only got a couple
more minutes left here yeah McDonald's a
Burger King McDonald's
you don't they never steer this wrong
they it gets so much hate but you can't
prove like
like since they say McDonald's is like
space food
I mean people in space are living off it
they ain't that a short time so it's
good all right I like your approach
that's my logic like I used to work
there yeah I like McDonald's I've been
eating my whole life and I ain't never
had no problems
nice job done who you what who you like
who you said what was the other one or
Burger King Burger King disappointed me
the Burger don't taste the same no more
like well in the 90s though no in the
90s it was amazing
dope they changed to me they got a
different meat now and I'm telling you
this Burgers like if you take all this
all the condiments off and just eat it
it tastes like cardboard oh yeah and
then you know over there you're not
getting out of McDonald's for under 65
bucks now if you got kids
that's why I got one go to a restaurant
or go to McDonald's that's why I got one
daughter and she love that Big Mac
all right let's wrap it up your last one
and in the 90s who were you more a fan
of Michael Jackson or Michael Jordan
Michael Jackson
I was a Michael Jordan hater because I
used to like Dominique Wilkins oh [__]
and I was really mad that he got beat in
there
Dunk Contest yeah damn the disgust
Michael Jackson yeah I love it yo I look
like Michael Jordan but I mean I respect
him over time once you get older than
you like nah he was a goat but yeah back
then I was a Dominique Wilkins fan
yeah people like that I could do it like
I grew up on Mike Tyson like like if it
was a little more like if Floyd was out
when I grew up that would have been your
guy I probably would have tried the Box
you know what I'm saying so it's been
inspired that I would have been inspired
because it's like I see because when I
like I said we kill him on Mike Tyson so
with Mike Tyson you look at him he was
like God yeah like you you you didn't
think he nobody could be like when he
lost I cried my mom did too Buster
Douglasville I couldn't believe it yeah
couldn't believe it
I thought the world was over I thought I
died but
that's how powerful he was so if I if it
was somebody that
like my size
I would have been this business yeah
man oh [__] all right so I wrapped up
yeah I wrapped it up do you have a
special coming out
anytime soon
I got music coming out you know what I'm
saying that's why I'm putting out my
music next and then I'm like I'm doing
this back on my feet tour I'm doing
getting back into filming how can
everybody uh get tickets for your tour
oh [__] ticketmaster.com
ticketmaster.com
on the screen I pop up boom right here
yep all right so you're back on your
feet tour you say you're getting back in
the film what are you doing or can you
talk about it
just doing films what I love to do you
know what I'm saying getting into a
series you know I'm saying doing stuff
that I like to do or something that that
I feel like I could put my energy in and
flip into another level you know
oh yeah the black effect I forgot about
the black fit podcast something to start
doing too they've been trying to get me
do podcasts for a while but like I told
you earlier I just I like being free
yeah people don't understand the
commitment of text yeah I do well yeah I
guess that's why I never got my friends
like great idiots they've been doing
they've been telling me to do it since
then like 10 years ago yeah they're one
of the first shows people don't realize
that yeah there you go seven them Joe
all of them like that they installed
that [__] like they they really did
start brilliant idiots back when Rogan
started yeah they started it you know
what I'm saying they was and when they
saw they told me to do it because like
all this real cool me Andrew and
Charlamagne like we like brothers in
this game you know what I'm saying we
came up together so they always told me
but it's like y'all say I don't I if I
don't feel like I'm gonna put the
commitment in it I don't like it yeah
I'm saying like I'm not gonna just do it
for a week and then because I know how I
am because I'm I move we're gonna let
the fans down yeah yeah I move with and
my fans they know how I am too I move
with With the Wind you know what I'm
saying I like to move like that and it's
it works for me but with this
it's a job and I don't see nothing like
a job but so it's like now I figured out
how to make it have fun and just do it
how I want to do it and make it make
sense why I want to just be
conversations and stuff I wanna I wanna
be like since since podcast evolved now
it ain't just conversation you can do
other things and then accept it so
that's what I'm doing with the podcast
[__] let's go good [__] all right all
right good [__]
yeah it's cool it's cool I didn't ask
you a question right after okay so we
got off the topic that's my way out
sometimes I'm sorry and don't use that
[__] on me if I do that to somebody else
please
um but yeah no no and it's got hash in
it and I was able to smoke it it burned
white it's got a resin ring you should
release that everywhere I'm gonna try to
man cool packaging I will say it too
it's the most I like one thing you can
put it anywhere bomb bomb look at it Go
bum bum put it in your hoodie
no that's cool I like it I like it and
it's safety you know I got the little
safety thing on there you gotta have
your little fish huh it's legal it's
legal
all right so where can everybody follow
you on social media just a little Duvall
everywhere a little Duvall on Instagram
little Duvall on Twitter a little Duval
on Facebook
Spotify and when you release music
listen Apple music Apple music and
YouTube I'm assuming right YouTube
you know
um
like I said like I've been doing this
[__] so long it's almost like it's hard
for me like it's just me so I don't know
what people own no more because
yeah it's like our community is like I
don't know
where everybody is because I do all it
so I mean just the baby I'm kind of
everywhere even if I ain't there
somebody's representing me the doing
something even like some most of stuff
on YouTube is somebody else to post it
on me oh no [__] yeah so well it's going
out there it's all circulation exactly
same [__] you know what I'm saying all
right is that all Marty yeah thank you
sir we appreciate you coming out you
smoked the whole damn time bro good [__]
most aggressive guess most aggressive
smoker we had here for real I appreciate
that one more time before I get out of
here I was thinking you got it all right
all right all right let's do it well
were you heading after this you said you
got some [__] to do today you can't do
mushrooms
um
he can do shows oh [__]
no them shits all night though I'll be
on the news for six hours yeah see Mike
when he went on Rogan he was talking
about smoking toad Venom that's my whole
other [__] that shit's crazy right it's
dead they they secrete the Venom from
this like indigenous Toad and there's
like a DMT oh no I'm not doing it yeah
you never see those fools they have a
Charmander in a river who did that you
no no you ever see the documentaries on
it don't have a shaman they'll be in a
river with moving water they smoke it
they hold them down people start [__]
tripping it's like 40 second thing they
come back and like I was gone I was
doing all this crazy it's like DMT but
they get the secretions of the Frog
they just it's like comes out of their
Joe
Rogan oh that's when Ty said he almost
died was that what the time
he was just explaining to him I mean now
he almost there he thought he almost
died yeah
yeah
there's a certain type of frog in this
country to get that [__] Venom you
ready
let's go
a little harder
now as hard as you can
take one breath all the way out
then they go for it
you rip the [__] out of this one the
last one
you good
it's any more water cleared no it's just
tilt it back
I did it so it was tilted back we hit it
good [__]
all right
good no no
coming out
now we got [__] joints and [__] still
all right cool cool appreciate you man
thank you for being here damn we just I
never had nobody hit the ball like that
on the on the show I don't know
appreciate you it's legendary all right
well guys thank you so much for being
here appreciate you Marty thank you for
being here everybody this has been Lil
Duvall from the dope as usual podcast
have a dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie